I've already talked about this a little before
If I just lift and turn the sword,
something is an
action of only my hands That's the kind of
mind that tells you what you need to
do
[music]
You can certainly do something like that
then you'll have to train more
it should happen naturally
[music]
when
we arenow the
first part
[music]
here's the moment when the leg goes back
[music] [
music] [music
]
[music]
when everything is coordinated
you can turn snow into heavy water
because snow is water water It's snow
You don't have to be a scientist to understand
that you can get a lot of water from snow
everyone can Understand how light snow can
be
but compress it
[music]
this is also an amount of snow only you
transform it into something
we can create this force mentally
[music]
perform this movement with your whole body
and then you become free at
the moment I don't see that any
of you understood
you are all trying very hard but no one is
succeeding
there is something to think about remember the examples
When you  go and stay calm
Maybe you'll figure it out when you're
driving or just taking
a walk
When the Shape Change happens
Try a little more
[music]
He's already gone
the better you get the
faster you do it
[music]
when you're a kid you start
learning it slowly
[music]
start thinking we're not
a kid anymore
[music]